Like it or not it's rhythm's game
now i've always loved a little puzzle
the hell are you supposed to be vengeance
vengeance you're becoming quite a celebrity
boy hear everything they say ancient
don't you ever just say hello
this is your legacy bruce wayne
oh this guy's hilarious
i got you
come on vengeance who are you under there
are you just hidiously scarred yeah
the batman
riddler's asking for you this is by far the most
major adversary he's come across the killer left
this for the boat man why is he writing to
you i've been trying to reach you you're
a part of this too the redless seems to know
secrets about that that even bruce didn't know
oh my god oh you're really not as
smart as i thought you were dick
it's gotham in a way that i
hadn't i haven't seen before
gordon reaches out to batman i think out of
a level of desperation unbelievable breaking
news gotham was murdered last night we have a
villain in the riddler who's all about clues
and also the riddler is addressing
everything directly to batman
any of this mean anything to you
you're pretty good at that catwoman
meets batman who's looking for
a serial killer in gotham new friend of
yours i'm not so sure they're both people who
fight for what they believe in they aren't
afraid to die from what they believe in
what's black and blue and dead all over
he wants to end up punishing the riddler
because he's being a mirror to bruce's secrets
there's latest it's all about the wings all
these years you lied to me alfred i'm just here
to unmask the truth about this cesspool we call
a city maybe this is all coming to an end hey
we all have our scars bruce
Welcome back everyone
this will be my new batman trailer video there's a
whole bunch of new footage easter eggs to break
down matt reeves and robert pattinson have also
been talking about the sequel mr freeze the court
of owls i'll explain what's going on with them
inside the new universe of batman movies that matt
reeves is creating freeze that's mr freeze to you
batman into the bat verse with all these different
versions across the multiverse if you're brand new
to the channel i'll be doing a bunch of videos
for the movie i'm supposed to see it a couple
days early i think i'm allowed to post my review
at the end of the month so look out for that too
but i'll start with the brand new footage then
i'll talk about mr freeze and then i'll talk
about the court of owls because everybody's been
talking about the court of owls since they dropped
the first teaser trailer for this movie like are
they going to be doing the court of owls in this
universe based on what robert pattinson is saying
odds are pretty good but i love the way they open
this new footage with the vengeance montage
like every new batman villain when they see
him is going to turn it into a meme now vengeance
vengeance vengeance and even though the riddler is
meant to be the main villain of this first movie
you see a ton of the penguin character in this
the way matt reeves described the penguins story
during the movie is that he said it's sort of an
origin story for his character just like it's an
origin story for catwoman as well some of you may
have figured this out but penguin in this movie
is a low-ranking member of the carmine falcone
crime family in the batman hbo spin-off series
that they're doing for colin farrell's penguin
character in the next year or two is actually
going to be a little bit like scarface inside
the dc universe me i want what's coming to me
or what's coming to you the world should go
and everything in it i believe the club that he's
running in the movie is a version of the iceberg
lounge though from the comics for those of you
that have been asking about carmine falcone too
because he's such a big character during batman
the long halloween and there's so much of this
movie that borrows from that storyline we finally
get some more carmine falcone footage tying him
to thomas wayne in the context of the long
halloween carmine falcone has history with
the wayne's thomas wayne who's a doctor saved
carmine falcone's life a long time ago and
became indebted to him so it sort of brought him
closer to the wanes and because the waynes are
billionaires because they've been so wealthy
for so many generations in the present day of
the story he's trying to get bruce wayne who
he does not know as batman to put his money in
mob controlled banks and obviously bruce wayne
doesn't want to have anything to do with him
but that's what the riddler's clue here means
when he scribbled sins of the father on this
here it just means that thomas wayne got caught
up with the mob in gotham city carmine falcone
the riddler's big thing in gotham is that he's
trying to expose all the most corrupt powerful
people in the city him killing the mayor at the
beginning of the film sort of sets that off and
the funny thing about that other clip where robert
pattinson is saying that the riddler is revealing
things to batman like he's leaving messages
directly to batman revealing things about his past
that even batman didn't know about his past that
clip actually came from a little caesars pizza
featurette like little caesars did an integration
with the movie you can actually see their ad
in the background here of this sort of times
square version of gotham city hopefully those
many millions of dollars they spent to get that ad
in there was worth it for them most of these are
just random businesses there are a couple other
easter eggs in here and all these advertisements
this whole anti-drug ad that you see all over this
scene here where it says stop the drops with this
line through it it's sort of like their version
of dare in universe in the context of the movie
in present day the drops are supposed to be this
new designer drug that's being circulated around
gotham maybe by the mob maybe by carmine falcone
but they're supposed to be really really bad so i
think they're part of the corruption that the
riddler's trying to expose like these really
powerful people are behind the drops in gotham
when they're investigating the mayor's murder at
the beginning of the film you see this broadcast
where this reporter is talking about the mayor's
murder and likening it to the murder of thomas and
martha wayne these people in this broadcast aren't
meant to be thomas martha wayne and bruce wayne
that's the mayor his wife and his son the little
kid from the funeral scene that i posted a couple
weeks ago i'll link that below in the description
they posted almost the entire clip of the funeral
scene with the riddler attacking in his next big
clue involving gail coulson who's one of the other
corrupt powerful people in gotham that the riddler
targets gil coulson is a district attorney who's
just this really really terrible person the whole
idea being that the riddler creates these traps
these riddles that batman has to solve in order to
try and save the people but it sounds like most of
them wind up dying especially early on in the film
for those of you that are hoping to see a
version of two-face show up in these movies
my early theory is that they kill gil coulson
off so the city needs a new district attorney
in that new district attorney winds up being
harvey den and maybe they do his origin story
in one of the batman sequels then i think all the
details about his past that the riddler is showing
to batman that he's learning about for the first
time are all about the gotham city orphanage in
their childhood together i talked about this in
my previous trailer videos it seems like based
on the evidence that the riddler is giving batman
he grew up inside the gotham city orphanage and
something terrible happened to them and he blames
thomas and martha wayne for whatever happened but
bruce was around for a lot of that like at some
point he and the riddler were childhood friends
and because his whole thing is solving riddles he
has solved the riddle of batman's secret identity
like he's figured out that it is bruce wayne
i mean because he knew bruce wayne as a child
that's why he's sort of taunting him with
all these details about his childhood
but just talking about mr freeze and the court
of owls so you may have heard matt reeves talking
about mr freeze basically saying that he is
going to be the main villain of the sequel to
the batman movie the monster who took you from
me will soon learn that revenge is a dish best
served cold he did say that he was going to take
a break before he started working on the sequel
movie so it'll probably be three years before
it comes out right now their plan is to do the
batman hbo spin-off series right after the batman
movie like he'll start working on that right away
he's got two series already with a couple other
spin-offs in the works most of those will be hbo
series we know about the colin farrell penguin
hbo series and then there's a gotham city one
with gordon being one of the main characters it'll
be kind of like the peacemaker series coming after
the suicide squad movie with like all the movie
characters coming back it's like their version
of the marvel disney plus series except with
batman robert pattinson was the one that was
talking about doing court of owls as one of the
big villains in the sequel movies during the very
first teaser trailer a couple years ago it seems
like it's been a couple years since that very
first trailer most of us were picking up a lot
of cordoval vibes but it sounds like they don't
really get into that during this first movie so
i think they'll save a lot of that for maybe the
second or the third film if mr freeze is gonna be
the big villain of the second film it sounds like
they'll just continue doing more origin stories
for batman's rogues gallery villains like the
really big villains and then maybe in the final
film they'll do corvallis as the main villain
i actually think that's a pretty smart thing to do
because most people think the joker would always
be the biggest batman villain but they've done the
joker so many times making the court of alice the
main villain just pushes into new territory you
can still do the joker as a big villain in the
matt reeves batman universe but it allows you
to do him in a very different way than you've
seen before so everybody post all your mr freeze
and your court of owl's theories in the comments
below if they're planning on doing those in the
sequel movies they can actually legit do the
court of owls as a full-on hbo series either way
if you're a big batman fan you're gonna be eating
good for the next several years there's gonna
be so much batman going around between michael
keaton's batman ben affleck's batman and the flash
movie and then obviously all the robber patents
and batman stuff that's going on like i said my
review video should be posting next week look out
for that make sure you enable alerts so you don't
miss it my full easter eggs breakdown videos any
post credit scenes that stuff will start posting
after the movie comes out at the end of next week
everyone click here for my peacemaker justice
league deleted scene video with batman
and click here for my brand new doctor
strange multiverse of madness trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!